morales que de venir en aide à ce peuple
qui a souffert tant par le passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou du
symbolisme en terme de timing ce sera
absolument parfait et ils veulent une
fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent tu sais
c'est que dalle en fait ces pilotes donc
si vous voulez aujourd'hui être affiché
à travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde et ses rêvés pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons de manière plutôt
méliorative plutôt faible
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mus nous ensemble comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi jusqu'à
21h30 pour décrypter les gros titres de
l'actualité de la journée au sommaire de
ce jeudi 30 septembre les adolescents de
12 à 17 ans doivent désormais présenter
un qr code impasse sanitaire obligatoire
pour se rendre au cinéma dans les
piscines les cafés restaurants ou encore
pour prendre le train les sorties
scolaires sont aussi concernés 1 parce
que le gouvernement risque de prolonger
jusqu'à l'été 2022 alors comment les
parents vivent t-il cette obligation
cette extension se justifie t'elle
vraiment réactions et des bas dans un
instant
elle a une de l'actualité d'affaires
bygmalion nicolas sarkozy condamné à un
an de prison ferme pour financement
illégal de sa campagne de 2012 un
système de fausses factures mis en place
pour camoufler le dépassement du plafond
légal une peine jugée trop sévère à
droite c'est la deuxième condamnation de
l'ancien président en un an après l
affaire des écoutes alors concrètement
comment et contrôler le financement de
la campagne présidentielle faut-il
prévoir le revoir le système français
réponse est en jeu à sept mois de la
présidentielle
pas de discussion possible entre la
corée du nord et les états unis le
leader nord-coréen rejette l'offre de
dialogue de washington
pyonyang qui vient de procéder à un tir
de missile hypersonique une avancée
technologique majeure qui pousse le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a convoqué
une réunion d'urgence demain mais kim
jong-un accepte la main tendue de son
voisin du sud
[Musique]
comment soulager le porte-monnaie des
français le premier ministre jean castex
doit faire plusieurs annonces dans les
prochaines minutes des êtres très
attendue par les ménages avec la hausse
du carburant du prix du gaz ou encore de
l'électricité les coupons seront ils
suffisants notamment pour éviter la
grogne des français cette flambée des
prix qui pourrait peut-être aviver la
colère des gilet jaune analyses et
débats suite dans le 21 heures
plus plus de restaurants ni de sport en
club s'en passe sanitaire pour les plus
de 12 ans depuis ce matin le
gouvernement qui veut par ailleurs
prolongé se passe pour tous quasiment un
an on en parle tout de suite avec à
notre reporter david khalifa devant le
ministère de la santé bon ce soir david
alors les parents ne sont pas forcément
pour ce pas ceux exigés pour les
mineures mais ils ne sont pas les seuls
à s'y opposer david
effectivement à stéphanie éligibles
depuis le mois de juin les adolescents
de 12 à 17 ans ont tous obtenu un sursis
et de 2 mois ils doivent maintenant
montrer patte blanche lui aussi comme
pour les adultes dans les mêmes endroits
que les ailes du temps tout cas les bars
les restaurants les bibliothèques les
théâtres les cinémas bien encore les
piscines alors beaucoup estiment que
c'est la seule solution pour retrouver
une vie normale mais d'autres sont
beaucoup plus réfractaires à cette idée
écouter
alors moi je suis pas pour que ça soit
obligatoire mais je pense que c'est
quand même une bonne chose parce que on
sait que les jeunes en contamine mais ça
ne touche pas en contamine plus les plus
vieux donc je pense que c'est une bonne
chose pour pour l'école au lycée on sait
que au lycée on saute amine beaucoup
donc je suis plutôt favorable à ça alors
malgré que je sais que c'est la seule
sortie pour cette crise c'est quand même
un peu un peu agaçant pour par exemple
les plus jeunes ceux de 12 ans 13 ans
qui sort encore avec leurs parents et
que leurs parents peuvent être coincé
par par leurs enfants qui n'ont pas
encore le pass and it erp ou autre chose
après c'est la seule c'est la seule
solution donc
on est obligé en fait d'accord parce que
c'est l'état qui a décidé voilà c'est
une aberration sont jeunes en bonne
santé il n'y a aucune raison nécessité
de mettre un vaccin à des enfants qui
sont en pleine santé qui sont en train
de se développer ou le système
immunitaire et des eaux plutôt que de
toute façon ils veulent pas qu'ils aient
de vie normale et puis on peut pas avoir
de vie normale dans ces conditions c'est
pas une vie de devoir présenter un pass
pour rentrer pour l'acheter un hamburger
ou sinon site au point un jeu c'est pas
non plus une vie enfin qu'on n'a jamais
connu ça donc c'est plus une prison à
ciel ouvert donc c'est une aberration
j'avoue j'ai pas tellement suivi le fil
d'actualités des différentes parce
sanitaire je suis moi même pas vacciner
c'est pas forcément quelque chose que je
cautionne bien que je comprenne il est
d'une vaccination maintenant pour les 12
17 ans j'ai cru comprendre
qu'effectivement c'était quand même un
terrain c'est important de propagation
du virus donc fait éventuellement si la
vaccination de mener obligatoire ça me
pose un cadre de plus de problèmes mais
le passé militaire ça laisse aussi la
possibilité d'un pc air derrière donc
pourquoi pas un test pcr qui deviendra
payant à partir de la mi-octobre et
c'est là aussi que ça peut poser
problème pour les jeunes qui refusent de
se faire vacciner qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens à de payer un test
pcr alors ça concerne environ 5 millions
de personnes en france selon elle les
données du ministère de la santé 71 %
des 12 17 ans ont déjà reçu au moins une
injection soit la 3 millions à 600
milles adolescents 1500000 elle reste à
vacciner les conséquences économiques
elles sont réelles et elles vont
inspecter de de nombreux secteurs
notamment les bars et les restaurants
car de nombreux jeunes à la sortie de li
du lycée se rassemblent se réunissent
dans des cafés ou des bars et pour les
gérants et bien c'est encore plus
compliqué à gérer ça ajoute une certaine
contrainte et pour eux mécaniquement est
grave il va y avoir une baisse de la
clientèle c'est la crainte première inde
et des professionnels qui imaginent que
les jeunes non vaccinés ne souhaite plus
revenir dans les bars ou dans les
restaurants les clubs sportifs également
sont touchés ils subissent cette
nouvelle mesure beaucoup ne souhaitent
plus pratiqué de sport collectif s'il
faut présenter un test négatif ou un
schéma vaccinal complet et david
l'exécutif qui réfléchit également une
prorogation de ce pass and i ter jusqu'à
l'été prochain
donc après la présidentielle des
annonces de gabriella talent qui font
beaucoup réagir évidemment
oui le pass sanitaire qui devait
s'arrêter au 15 novembre pourrait
finalement être exigée jusqu'à l'été
2022 c'est en tout cas le souhait de
l'exécutif
à en croire les mots du porte-parole du
gouvernement
un avant-projet de loi a même été
transmis au conseil d'état qui va
remettre un avis au gouvernement ce qui
forcément interroge du côté de
l'opposition sur le timing mais aussi
sur la fiabilité et de l'exécutif
florian philippot le chef de file des
patriotes sur twitter rappelle écoliers
vers ans avait affirmé que le pass annie
terre ne serait pas prolongé au-delà du
15 novembre le 25 juillet est dernier et
accusent le gouvernement de menteur le
sénateur républicain à laon père se
demande lui aussi où sont les limites du
pouvoir quant au sénateur bruno
retailleau l et es présidentielle sont
problématiques le sénat ne pourra pas
autorisé le gouvernement à prolonger ce
pass sanitaire vous l'aurez compris les
débats au sein de l'assemblée tout comme
au sénat risque d'être houleux merci
david kelly femmes pour ces précisions
leurs pattes sanitaire désormais pour
les adolescents et prolongation pour les
adultes le tout dans un contexte
épidémique au plus bas est ce vraiment
utile socialement acceptable c'est
l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
bruno megaman vous êtes chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris merci d'être avec nous à vous
pouvez nommer germann à vos côtés
charlène à vos côtés un peu plus loin en
bretagne 1 charlène tel boulet vous êtes
professeur de danse 1 en bretagne je le
disait merci à vous d'être va également
avec nous un mot tout d'abord sur ce
pass and it ra obligatoire des 12-17 ans
ça y est on y est charlène taboulé à
vous qui êtes prof de danse justement
parler des clubs de sport il ya un
instant qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement pour vous est-ce que ça
impacte votre activité
oui oui totalement en fait on a repris
mi septembre
avec déjà beaucoup de questions d'ego au
niveau de cette tranche d'âge parce que
ben beaucoup de parents ne sont pas
prêts à faire vacciner leurs enfants
juste pour pouvoir aller à la danse ou
chou toi n'importe quel de l'activité
donc une grosse baisse des inscriptions
de cette tranche d'âge
quasiment de moitié pour certains pour
certains cours et certaines disciplines
de moitié ça veut dire moitié moins
demande de piqué à cette obligation et
et les parents vous le dis c'est
vraiment en raison de cette volonté de
se faire vacciner
ah oui bien sûr des cours alors moi je
suis juste une petite rectification je
suis pas en bretagne je suis dans l'aude
[Musique]
c'est une petite structure donc on va
dire gg des cours de 8 10 élèves bah oui
sur sur lui sur un court de huit élèves
quand j'en ai 4 qui ne pourront plus
venir parce qu'elles sont pas vaccinés
c'est la moitié pour moi et c'est pas
que dans dans ce coup là il ya d'autres
et d'autres courent donc bien une baisse
d'effectif détective certaines limites
ça c'est sûr bruno megaman quand vous
entendez cette professeur de danse et
c'est vrai qu'on on en a vu des
témoignages voilà deux parents qui
préférait enlever leurs enfants des
cours de sport qui parfois sont même
lors leur passion ont raison de se
passer ni terre parce qu'il refuse de
faire vacciner leurs enfants ça ne vous
évoque quoi vous
je connais votre opinion évidemment ça
vous êtes vous ne comprenez pas vous
essayer de leur faire de la pédagogie et
je crois qu'ils ont tort pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement le virus circule
principalement auprès des personnes non
vaccinées et donc de fait les
adolescents ont envie d'avoir des
interactions sociales de vivre leur vie
quasi normalement de sortir d'aller
faire du sport et ils doivent pouvoir le
faire en plus grande sécurité donc le
fait effectivement d'être vacciné leur
permettra de réduire le risque d'être
contaminé de contaminer les autres de
développer éventuellement une forme
grave de la maladie voire de développer
un kobe de long il faut savoir que 10 %
des adolescents après une infection
aiguë peut-être peu symptomatiques
risque d'avoir des symptômes qui vont
durer pendant plusieurs mois et les
handicapés dans leurs activités
sportives ou culturelles le fait
évidemment le pass annie terre va
permettre de pousser ces adolescents à
la vaccination vous savez ce que
l'argument qui ressort à chaque fois
c'est que tout simplement cette
catégorie n'est pas en danger voilà
réellement c'est surtout pour protéger
les autres qu'est ce que le médecin leur
répond alors je dirais oui et non alors
c'est vrai qu'ils sont moins en danger
qu'une personne d'un âge plus avancé
avec des comorbidités malgré tout le
risque existe il faut savoir que avec le
variant delta plus contagieux eh bien on
a vu multiplier par deux le nombre
d'hospitalisation des enfants pour
femmes à travers moi je ne suis pas
pédiatre n'avons que des adultes mais
aussi multiplier par quatre le nombre
d'adolescents par rapport aux vagues
précédentes donc le risque existe même
si je suis tout à fait d'accord il est
mineur par contre le risque de kobe
delon lui existe quasiment de façon
équivalente par rapport aux adultes avec
des enfants qui ont été déscolarisés en
raison de symptômes chroniques qui ont
dû arrêter un certain d'activité en
raison de ses problèmes donc oui il y à
un bénéfice individuel direct mais
évidemment le l'intérêt principal c'est
de réduire la circulation du virus donc
de réduire le risque de contaminer des
parents proches qui ne seraient pas
vaccinés ou qui seraient immunodéprimées
et puis malgré tout de réduire le risque
d'émergence de variants on va donner la
parole évidemment charlène taboulé avant
cela je voudrais vous faire écouter
gabriel apte à la porte parole du
gouvernement qui lui en tout cas se
félicite évidemment de ce texte est de
se pavaner terre si on n'avait pas
bénéficié de la vaccination et du pass
sanitaires probablement que cet été au
vu des taux d'incidence qu'on a
constatée dans un certain nombre de
régions on aurait dû refermer les bars
les restaurants voire peut-être remettre
des couvre-feux airs confiné on n'a pas
eu à le faire parce qu'on dise qu'on
dispose de cet outil du pass sanitaire
qui vous savez que la possibilité d'y
recourir s'éteint au 15 novembre
prochain donc ce que nous voulons ce que
nous allons proposer au parlement c'est
de maintenir pendant plusieurs mois
encore jusqu'à l'été la possibilité d'y
recourir c'est ça qui va être proposé
dans ce texte de loi ensuite le conseil
d'état va nous remettre un avis il va y
avoir une discussion parlementaire pour
échanger sur ce sujet-là charitable et
quand vous entendez gabriela talent nous
dire voilà a permis tout de même un
retour à une certaine vie normale a une
certaine liberté qu'est ce que vous lui
lui répondez vous
alors d'accord je voudrais répondre aux
professeurs parce que j'ai beaucoup de
respect vous êtes vous êtes médecin et
moi non par contre j'ai encore
l'impression que c'est une mesure assez
incohérente tout comme quand on a eu des
fermetures administratives pour nos
écoles de danse au mois de novembre au
mois de janvier février alors que les
enfants continuaient à aller à l'école
donc là les enfants continuent à aller à
l'école et sont brassées dans ces écoles
ils sont pas moi je vous dis j'ai dix
douze élèves par parcours et dans les
écoles ils sont 35 par classe
de nouveau ça me semble une mesure
encore incohérente ensuite mais lorsque
j'entends dire
qu'il ya que le vaccin qui nous sortira
de cette histoire c'est pas possible
enfin maintenant quand même les langues
se délient des médecins qui parle il ya
des collectifs de médecins reinfo
coville et d'autre il existe des
traitements et qui ne sont pas et n'y a
pas d'étude l'ivermectine ya aucune
étude à grande envergure qui a été fait
parce que ça passait chez rectorat il
vole je suis raide pour moi c'est pas un
pass salutaire c'est juste pour nous
obliger à nous pousser à la vaccination
pour quel intérêt ça s'adresse à des
balles maintenant je suis pas sûr que
cette mesure soit cohérente surtout
quand on est en train peut justement de
voir même les mémés grands médias le
disent qu'il ya de moins en moins de cas
et si on regarde les véritables chiffres
du de réseau sentinelles je sais pas si
vous connaissez le réseau sentinelles
mais c'est quand même
c'est quand même sous tutelle de
l'inserm de la sorbonne
c'est un groupe qui regardent justement
les épidémies la semaine dernière
avec un taux de 4,9 pour cent mille
habitants alors qu'on parle d'épidémie
canton à 170 malade pour cent mille
habitants donc là on n'est plus du tout
dans une phase épidémique je ne sais pas
trop vraiment sont justement ceux
passani terre et à cette vaccination
moi je pense pas puisque on n'arrête pas
nous dire que ce vaccin ne protège pas
qu'on peut être contaminé qu'on peut
être vecteur alors oui il protège
peut-être des formes graves dans ce
cas-là vaccinant les personnes à risque
les personnes âgées les personnes qui
ont des commodités mais pourquoi
vacciner tout le monde bientôt ce sera
les enfants de 0 à 12 ans enfin il ya un
moment donné voilà mes mails que des
mensonges nous avait dit monsieur
matheron avait dit le pas le pardon le
bassin ne sera pas obligatoire c'est une
obligation cacher quand on est obligés
d'imposer à nos employés de se vacciner
sinon on est obligé de les licencier
c'est une matinée c'est une obligation
cacher je suis désolé et là il avait dit
le passera pas il va pas s'arrêter aux
plaintes non y'a que des mensonges il
faut que les gens s'informent autrement
on va laisser justement répondre le
docteur des mensonges docteur sais c'est
ce que pense une partie en tout cas de
la population en france et ailleurs je
crois qu'ils ont tort donc en fait
effectivement là où je suis d'accord le
pass vaccinale a pour but de pousser à
la vaccination du plus grand nombre le
plus rapidement possible d'ailleurs
c'est grâce à cette vaccination que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une bien
meilleure situation
si nous n'étions pas avec une couverture
vaccinale aussi élevé en métropole eh
bien nous aurions vécu la même situation
qu aux antilles c'est à dire qu'on est
ce qu'on n'aurait pu sortir de la crise
que
avec un confinement strict donc c'est ce
que l'on veut éviter et c'est ce qu'on
on est en train d'éviter même si
évidemment il ya un risque de poussée
épidémique cet hiver avec le
refroidissement des températures mais au
moins les personnes
fragiles seront protégés grâce à la
vaccination de faire une forme grave ça
veut dire que toute la population c'est
ce que semble dire madame que toute la
population doit se faire vacciner pour
protéger les personnes fragiles alors
d'abord bien sûr en premier lieu les
personnes les plus fragiles doivent
absolument se faire vacciner ensuite
comme je les dis les personnes moins à
risque et bien doivent aussi se faire
vacciner parce que le risque existera
toujours de faire une forme grave n'est
pas nul c'est dommage quand même de
prendre un risque de mourir même en
étant plus jeune
alors que le vaccin est simple à
acquérir gratuit protège est très bien
toléré et aujourd'hui on a un recul très
important avec plus de 5 milliards de
personnes qui ont reçu ce vaccin donc il
n'y a vraiment aucun danger de se faire
vacciner ensuite je rappelle
effectivement ce sont les formes dont on
parle moins qu'ils sont par exemple à
kovy de long qui malgré tout menace les
personnes même plus jeunes même qui
feront des formes moins grave d'être
handicapé dans la suite de leur vie
qu'on précise bien la confidence est
quoi la fatigue alors voilà c'est en
fait c'est la persistance de symptômes
au delà de l'infection aiguë parfois
trois mois huit mois 12 mois après
l'infection essentiellement des plaintes
de fatigue d'essoufflement à l'effort
mais parfois aussi divers symptômes qui
touchent différents organes et
aujourd'hui on sait que ceci est lié à
une inflammation de certaines régions du
cerveau à cause du virus charlène
taboulé je pense avoir vous avez des
enfants vous quelle est votre position
aujourd'hui
par rapport à ce pas sanitaire
obligatoire pour eux parce que c'est
vrai que quand on voudra prendre le
train avec les envoyait aux sports quand
on est voilà pas forcément pour ce
vaccin ça devient compliqué
oui oui c'est compliqué mois bien sûr
mon les enfants sont pas encore
concernés mais j'ai parce qu'ils sont
petits encore huit ans cinq ans et vingt
mois mais ce sera peut-être bientôt le
retour par contre oui j'ai des nièces
des neveux fin qui sont concernés non je
pense que c'est pour moi c'est une et
c'est une aberration je pense aussi
qu'il faudrait un peu reparler aux gens
de leur terrain leur système immunitaire
quand même le coc vite on a vu que chez
certaines personnes ça me fait rien du
tout chez d'autres personnes bah oui ça
les envoie en réanimation il ya un
moment donné ça dépend aussi beaucoup du
terrain des des gens donc les jeunes les
enfants il faut les préparer à une
meilleure nutrition à avoir un système
immunitaire qui fonctionne il n'y a pas
que les médicaments pour soigner et pour
moi certains sincèrement obliger
quelqu'un à prendre un médicament quel
qu'il soit je veux dire il ya des gens
qui refusent de faire des
chimiothérapies c'est leur droit un
moment donné on
obliger quelqu'un à s'injecter un
produit quel qu'il soit prendre un
médicament boire quelque chose pour moi
c'est inacceptable
donc annoncé retenant les enfants on
toucherait pas là mais en france ça
c'est sûr renault megane c'est vrai que
c'est une conversation quand même autant
il ya beaucoup d'adultes voilà qui sont
peut-être prêts à se faire vacciner
quoique hop voilà certains s'en sont
récalcitrants
mais peut-être beaucoup de parents aussi
qui hésitent qui sont inquiets pour
leurs enfants qui se sentent obligés de
le faire il y avait beaucoup de parents
moi en tout cas qui m'ont dit ça qu'ils
se sentent obligés pour les raisons
qu'on a invoqué est ce que en tant que
médecin vous garantissez à ses parents
qu'il n'y a aucun danger sur un enfant
de 12 ans qui n'a pas terminé cette
croissance
écoutez les les études sont là c'est pas
moi qui garantit ce sont les études
scientifiques qui ont démontré que le
vaccin est très bien tolérée et efficace
chez les adolescents d'ailleurs lire
également chez les enfants à partir de
l'âge de 5 ans mais aujourd'hui la
vaccination n'est pas encore possible
pour les enfants ensuite il ya le recul
que l'on a avec
aujourd'hui plus de 5 milliards de
personnes qui ont reçu une vaccination
donc on a suffisamment de recul pour
être sûr que ce vaccin est parfaitement
bien toléré bien sûr il ya des effets de
ces effets secondaires bien sûr il ya
des effets secondaires comme tout
médicament mais la balance bénéfice
risque reste parfaitement favorable elle
est
également chez les adolescents et donc
il faut être rassuré il faut pas en
faire toute une histoire beaucoup de
vaccins sont obligatoires
il faut bien savoir que dans l'idée de
vaccins il n'y a pas que la protection
individuelle il y a aussi
une
va dire une problématique de protection
de l'ensemble des individus donc
d'intérêt collectif qu'il faut avoir l
charlène taboulé quand on vous prend 17
arguments de protection collective
qu'est ce que qu est ce qu on vous
répondait mais j'ai beaucoup de mal avec
ça parce que comme je vous parlais du
système immunitaire alors oui c'est
triste pour les personnes à risque les
personnes âgées mais donc qu'elle se
vaccine mais je vous dire si ça fait des
années qu'on essaye de mieux manger de
faire attention d'être en bonne santé
moi j'étais en contact avec des gens qui
me locaux vides et j'ai attrapé
peut-être après peut-être ça me
travaille à peut-être j'ai déjà eu une
grosse grippe avec 40 de fièvre 41
personnes fragiles qui qui peuvent en
potentiellement aurait appelé son taxi
n'est alors elle ne devrait pas avoir
peur je veux dire à un moment donné
alors oui il y à il ya quelques effets
secondaires mais en fait c'est un peu la
roulette russe on ne peut pas savoir si
elle use nous faire quelque chose ou pas
moi j'ai très peur quand même avec cette
histoire de roulette russe concept
quelque chose on sait pas après on parle
beaucoup de vaccins c'est pas vraiment
un vaccin c'est ça ce serait bien que
que les médias essayez un peu de donner
de bonnes informations
la surface et un arn messagers ça
s'appelle pas un vaccin ça je veux dire
les voilà après j'ai beaucoup de mal
avec ça de de nous forcer à le faire si
on pense qu'il faut le faire qu'on se
sent un risque que chacun ait sa propre
opinion et cons et qu'on la respecte
mais on ne peut pas forcer avec ce
chantage c'est quand même un chantage
immonde je suis désolé de dire s'il
était pas venu venir travailler à partir
du 1er septembre c'est vraiment du
chantier soignants et les pompiers voilà
ça fait en catégorie relégables ils ont
pris de restauration les professeurs
dedans
non c'est pas que pour les soignants
tous les gens qui sont en contact avec
du public nommé garbade quand on n'y
avait que c'est pas un vaccin c'est un
arn messagers qu'est ce qu'elle fait et
c'est cette notion c'est bien un vaccin
c'est à dire un vaccin c'est un produit
que l'on va administrer qui va stimuler
la réponse immunitaire c'est bien le cas
ça n'est en aucun cas une thérapeutique
génétique qui modifie le patrimoine
génétique là dessus aussi on a beaucoup
d'arguments formelle qui est qui
certifie qu'il n'y a aucune modification
du patrimoine génétique l'aide la
deuxième chose on va dire importante à
bien à bien comprendre c'est que quand
en se vaccinant même si on a peu de
risques de faire une forme grave on
réduit le risque de diffusion du virus
de contamination des autres or danse
danse dans sa famille autour de soi on a
des personnes qui peut être sont
immunodéprimés qui sont plus âgés dans
le système immunitaire peut être ne
répond pas de façon optimale aux vaccins
eh bien ça serait dommage qu'un jeune
soit à l'origine de la contamination de
ces personnes il faut donc avoir une
démarche altruiste aussi avec cette
maladie merci en tout cas à tous les
deux vous avez exprimée en tout cas
votre point de vue charden taboulé vous
aussi vous nommez garden merci à vous
deux
et avec l'extension du pass sanitaires
un la question des libertés publiques
est à nouveau mis sur la table
évidemment le conseil d'état pointe des
excès de la part du gouvernement
français depuis 2015 le recours à l'état
d'urgence d'abord face aux risques
terroristes puis aux corridas étaient
trop fréquent c'est la vie qui émettent
les sages dans leur enquête annuelle les
sages qui propose quinze propositions
les explications en images
nous
[Musique]
non
où
[Musique]
[Rires]
nicolas sarkozy condamné à un an de
prison ferme pour financement illégal de
sa campagne présidentielle de 2012
l'ancien chef de l'état reconnu a été
reconnu coupable par le tribunal
correctionnel de paris dans la sphère
bygmalion sur les réseaux sociaux il a
dénoncé une injustice écouter
on ne peut pas être sanctionné deux fois
pour les mêmes faits c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai interjeté appel afin
que la cour dise le droit j'irai
jusqu'au bout dans cette quête qui
dépasse mon cas personnel car chacun
peut un jour se trouver confronté à
l'injustice une bataille judiciaire qui
n'est pas terminé nicolas sarkozy a
annoncé aussitôt faire appel de son
jugement retour sur les événements avec
cyrielle bout et
le verdict est tombé pour nicolas
sarkozy l'ex président de la république
est déclaré coupable ce jeudi 2
financement illégal dans la sphère
bygmalion le tribunal correctionnel de
paris le condamne à un an de prison
ferme une peine plus lourde que celle
réclamée par le parquet qui préconisait
un an de prison dont six mois avec
sursis
nicolas sarkozy a annoncé par le biais
de son avocat son intention de faire
appel le président sarkozy avec lequel
je me suis entretenu au téléphone un
instant m'a demandé d'aller faire appel
ce que je ferai immédiatement en sortant
d'ici et naturellement le jugement ne
sera pas exécutoire la cour d'appel et
c'est pour ça que les cours d'appel
existent dira le droit et nous aurons
alors l'occasion
d'en reparler le président sarkozy n'a
jamais demandé à être mieux traité qu'un
autre
mais n'a aucune raison de l'être moins
bien je rappelle que la peine prononcée
et le maximum de la peine encourue est
alors même que jamais une juridiction ne
peut envisager une sanction maximum
lorsque le prévenu ce qui est son cas
aujourd'hui n'a jamais été condamné
absent ce jeudi lors du verdict nicolas
sarkozy ne s'est présenté qu'une seule
fois durant le procès lors de son
audition le 15 juin dernier une affaire
qui a débuté par une accusation dans la
presse deux ans après la campagne
présidentielle de 2012
44 meeting organisé à l'époque par l'
agence de communication bygmalion pour
le candidat ump pour un coût de 43
millions d'euros soit près du double du
plafond autorisé par la loi en 2012
13 autres prévenus ont été reconnus
coupables dans cette affaire parmi eux
jérôme lavrilleux ancien directeur
adjoint de la campagne de nicolas
sarkozy
j'ai pris perpet je ne voudrais jamais
la page de sa fera partie de ma vie on
ne peut pas l'évacuer on peut pas faire
comme si d'ailleurs dans ma vie j'ai
jamais fait comme si j'ai sans doute
commis des fautes je vais payer pour
mais pas celles qui m'avaient été
imputée au début de cette affaire la
présidente a reconnu qu'il n'y avait pas
eu de constitution de cagnotte de
détournement d'argent
par qui que ce soit c'est pour moi une
grande victoire
nicolas sarkozy devra purger sa peine à
domicile sous surveillance électronique
si la condamnation est confirmée en
appel après l affaire des écoutes
toujours en suspens depuis la demande
d'appel de nicolas sarkozy c'est la
deuxième condamnation de l'ex président
de la république nicolas sarkozy qui
n'est pas au bout de ses peines est
également mise en examen dans une
affaire de financement libyen lors de sa
campagne de 2007 l' enquête est toujours
en cours et la date du procès n'a pas
encore été communiquée
l'ancien chef de l'état risque jusqu'à
cinq ans de prison et 375 mille euros
damende est ce vers des cas fait réagir
la classe politique allaigrement
aujourd'hui écoutés il a fait appel
bond attendra de savoir comment comment
ça se passe on appelle pour pour donner
une opinion sur cette affaire je suis
j'ai un peu mal à l'aise parce que je
suis capable de voir le contraste avec
le jugement dont a fait l'objet le
monsieur balladur donc bon mais
honnêtement je peux rien en dire là
parce que il faut quand même savoir un
peu de quoi on parle on peut pas dire
simplement comme c'est monsieur sarkozy
que c'est un adversaire politique alors
tous les coups sont permis non c'est
vrai
pas en tout cas le rend des décisions
c'est déjà ça ça devrait être un
justiciable comme un autre
si les responsables des faits qui lui
sont incriminés c'est de la délinquance
c'est plus avoir une peine aménagée
pouvoir rester chez lui et alors même
que on lui impute des choses quand même
relativement grave il faut que la
justice passe je pense aussi que d'un
point de vue démocratique il faudrait
aussi qu'ils aient des mesures
démocratiques qui permettent aux
citoyens justement
de s'exprimer quand elles ne sont pas
satisfaits c'est la raison pour laquelle
pentium pro droits de révocation des
élus
nicolas sarkozy a été un grand président
de la république j'ai été fier
d'appartenir à son gouvernement et de sa
confiance je sais qu'il se battra
jusqu'au bout pour défendre son honneur
et je lui adresse aujourd'hui un message
d'amitié
sarkozy à nouveau condamné se
rendra-t-il de lui même en prison lui
qui était si féru de peines plancher et
automatique finalement la racaille c'est
lui nicolas sarkozy condamné à un an de
prison ferme dans l'affairé bygmalion
les juges des branches la dernière
perfusion qui aurait pu lui permettre de
jouer un rôle indirect dans la campagne
de 2022
le respect des lois le respect des
règles pour tout le monde sans exception
voici lajolo sarkozy va réaliser sa
peine d'un an pour financement illégal
de sa campagne
grâce à l'aménagement de sa peine et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct sur
ce plateau avec denis demonpion
journaliste indépendant qui a écrit à
plusieurs
devant sur nicolas sarkozy bonsoir denis
demonpion merci d'être avec nous la
justice at-elle démontré aujourd'hui que
nicolas sarkozy était un justiciable
justement comme les autres oui ni plus
ni moins parce que d'abord il a
profité bénéficier de conditions un peu
particulières parce que il n'a pas eu à
assister à toutes les audiences
uniquement quand c'était son
interrogatoire voilà donc en général
quand il ya un procès sur plusieurs
jours les prévenus sont tenus d'assister
à toutes les audiences c'est d'ailleurs
dans le passé ce qui avait été reproché
à alain juppé qui avait été poursuivi
aussi pour
financement illégal du rpr et il avait
été durement sanctionné en première
instance parce que justement il n'avait
pas assisté aux audiences et son avocat
il faut bien dire avait un peu laissé
filer la faire quoi mais dans le cas de
nicolas sarkozy
alors il est condamné à une peine d'un
an ferme il faut rappeler quand même que
c'est vrai que c'est la peine maximale à
l'époque parce que depuis la loi a été
revu aujourd'hui pour des mêmes faits il
encourrait trois ans de prison et 45000
euros d'amendé
dont voilà la peine n'est pas définitif
lorsque le tribunal correctionnel n'a
pas demandé le mandat de dépôt à
l'audience d'ailleurs il est rare que
pour des dans des affaires de ce type et
non pas parce que c'est nicolas sarkozy
mais dans les affaires financières il
est très très rare qu'on demande de
mandat de dépôt à l'audience donc il va
faire appel et sans doute vers nous à ce
moment là ce que l'appel peut faire mais
celui dont on a vu ça dans le passé avec
un ancien ministre socialiste qui était
roland dumas condamné lourdement en
première instance et relaxé en appel
alors tout espoir est permis pour lui
justement la droite elle a fustigé
évidemment une peine lourde on a entendu
les réactions tout à l'heure c'est une
décision vous estimez particulièrement
sévères notamment par rapport au
réquisitoire non mais écoutez le en tout
cas les attendus le le comment le
parquet dans son réquisitoire le
procureur de la république avait été
bon comme toujours vous savez avec les
prévenus il faut un peu la leçon bon là
il n'avait pas manqué d'asticoter un peu
nicolas sarkozy comme tout justiciable
il faut le rappeler est mais là le
tribunal dans ses attendus dans son
jugement a été beaucoup plus n'ont pas
réservé mais il n'a pas porter de
jugement de valeur il a simplement
constaté que les dépassements du
financement de la campagne était presque
du doute donc veut plus de 20 millions
d'euros et que nicolas sarkozy ne
pouvait pas ne pas savoir qu'il y avait
des déplacements dans ce qu'il avait été
informé par écrit et deux jours plus
tard aux trois jours plus tard il
demandait quand même à ce que des grands
meetings très coûteuse soit organisé
donc
sauf quand c'est votre argent de poche
vous faites attention là visiblement il
n'était pas très regardant sur d'où
venait l'argent à vous entendre de nîmes
demandes sont les magistrats aujourd'hui
en tout cas de ce tribunal correctionnel
ont démontré qu'ils étaient
insoupçonnable sur leur partialité on
sait très bien que les rapports entre la
justice et nicolas sarkozy n'ont jamais
été bon non c'est vrai mais je il ya ce
soupçon je ne crois pas vous avez dans
d'autres affaires ici on pense à l'
affaire bettencourt dans laquelle il a
été accroché aussi ça s'est terminée par
un non lieu dans cette affaire donc on
quand un homme politique quel qu'il soit
et condamnés même en première instance
on peut pas dire voilà la justice est
partial d'ailleurs la présidente du
tribunal ait et connaissait très bien
son dossier tous les tenants et
aboutissants il y avait quand même 14
prévenus au total elle avait très bien
travaillé le terrain et je pense pas
qu'elle ait eu d'animosité particulière
à l'encontre de nicolas sarkozy
simplement les faits sont les faits les
lois je le rappelle sont quand même je
vois aujourd'hui tous les hommes
politiques qui réagissent alors en bien
en mal selon
l'assignation seulement le parti auquel
j'appartiens de mai en tout cas
ce sont les députés et les
parlementaires qui font qu'ils votent
les lois n'est ce pas et ce sont souvent
les gouvernements qui les écrivent donc
si les politiques considèrent qu' il ya
des abus il devrait revenir sur ses lois
mais c'est pas les juges qui ont décidé
de porter ce type d'infraction
aujourd'hui à trois ans sauf que c'est
vrai que cette décision de justice est
là on le sait tous des conséquences
importantes sur nicolas sarkozy qui
ambitionnait certainement de revenir au
premier plan de la scène politique est
ce qu'il est officiellement mort
politiquement aujourd'hui alors écoutez
c'était une chanson un peu récurrente
c'est un refrain qu'on entend souvent le
retour de nicolas sarkozy dès qu'il
écrit un livre dès qu'il accorde une
longue interview etc parce que à droite
comme ils sont un petit peu désorienté
aujourd'hui avec la profusion de plans
dida et bien et que lui a été
véritablement le dernier président de
droite républicaine
vous savez on interroge toujours comme
un oracle mai
on l'a bien vu lors de la dernière
primaire à droite il n'avait pas réussi
à
passer le cap du premier tour et a
sélectionné donc il ya une espèce de
mythe autour d'un éventuel retour de
nicolas sarkozy au pouvoir
alors s'il veut peser dans la campagne
en soutenant tel ou tel candidat je
pense pas que cette condamnation le gêne
beaucoup quant à revenir aux affaires en
tant que président de la république se
présentait un jour ou l'autre ça paraît
très compromis pourquoi pas pour des
raisons d'affaires politico financières
et de scandales divers mais plus pour
son bilan de président voilà parce qu'il
ya une chose que les français ont pas
digéré et ça même des années après c'est
que il y avait ce référendum sur la
constitution vous savez le bonheur de
cette union européenne qui a été rejetée
par les français et une fois aux
affaires nicolas sarkozy a décidé de
s'appuyer sur sa majorité parlementaire
pour faire passer le texte et ça c'est
resté en travers de la gorge de beaucoup
de français raison pour laquelle
quand
paris où la france bruit de son éventuel
retour aux affaires il ya énormément de
réticences la dernière question on l'a
dit un ses condamnations pour
financement illégal de campagne ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui et de nicolas sarkozy
en a eu d'autres avant à droite comme à
gauche est ce que c'est le moment de
s'interroger et de remettre peut-être en
cause de changer ce système électoral
français alors écoutez la loi sur le
financement des partis politiques
remonte à 1990 d'ailleurs c'est à ce
moment là que une commission nationale
des comptes de campagne et des
financements
des publics a été créé avec pour objet
justement de vérifier au centime près
parce qu'il faut voir le travail que
font les membres de cette commission
pour éplucher les comptes de chacun des
candidats mais vraiment le sentiment
voyez je pense par exemple quand la juge
eva joly s'étaient présentés pour les
verts il avait épluché une une note une
facture de 42 euros qu'elle avait nombre
elle avait honoré cette facture avec son
argent de poche et la commission a
considéré que cette facture devait
porter passé sur les dons étant donné
les usages qui avait été fait de ses 42
ans donc c'est vous dire que c'est un
travail très sérieux et alors
depuis ça a quand même éviter pas mal
d'abus et pourquoi les députés et les
politiques ont-ils voté cette en 1990
parce que c'était après les affaires
politico financières qui ont mis à
genoux le parti socialiste les affaires
urba gracco les fausses factures les
pots de vin les marchés publics truqués
etc etc alors ça avait commencé avec le
parti socialiste de françois mitterrand
ensuite ça s'est étendu aux centristes
puis au rpr enfin tous les partis
étaient touchées et gagner et sous la
pression non pas des politiques mais de
l'opinion qui commençait à ruer dans les
brancards il a bien fallu donner un
cadre juridique et
malheureusement pour les politiques et
heureusement pour l'argent public
puisqu'il faut rappeler quand même que
les campagnes sont remboursés dès lors
un candidat fait plus de 5 % et même en
deçà d'ailleurs ils peuvent avoir droit
à certains remboursements donc c'est
quand même l'argent public donc il est
normal que le contribuable et les
lecteurs sachent un peu où va son argent
merci beaucoup aux denis demonpion
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse
est toujours au chapitre judiciaire la
suite du procès des attentats du 13
novembre une quinzaine d'auditions ont
eu lieu aujourd'hui devant la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris des rescapés
des proches de victimes des fusillades
qui avaient visé plusieurs terrasses
parisiennes étaient appelés à la barre
le point avec katia pique nique
aujourd'hui des victimes directes ou
proches de victimes du petit cambodge eu
la bonne bière du restaurant casa nostra
ou encore de la belle équipe se sont
exprimé d'une manière extrêmement digne
nous avons entendu les pleurs du père du
jeune musicologue et violoniste
originaire d'algérie qui marchait dans
la rue ce soir là l'émotion du patron de
la belle équipe 21 morts compagnon de
jamila tombé sur sa terrasse il appelle
à renforcer les valeurs républicaines et
s'est plaint de la requête
administrative poste attentats des
défaillances de la france pour les
victimes nous avons entendu cet homme
aux blessures très graves qui a perdu
son pied une partie de l'intestin
cet homme qui depuis aide les jeunes des
quartiers à s'exprimer à s'intégrer il
s'est adressé aux accusés un moment
extrêmement puissant je parle sans haine
at il dit je n'en ai jamais eu je vous
considère d'abord comme des êtres
humains vous avez une tête un coeur des
sentiments des émotions qu'est ce qui se
passe dans une tête pour qu'un jour on
décide à tuer at il dit alors lui aussi
peut reprocher à des choses à la france
at il dit mais comment avez vous pu
penser que la mort de centaines de
personnes ici aller venger les morts là
bas vous pensez que ça va mieux
maintenant at il demandé il est se dit
même prêt à pardonner à discuter mais
encore faut-il que vous le vouliez et
que vous ayez le courage d'être des
hommes beaucoup à la barre ont expliqué
que l'islam était une bonne religion une
religion de paix qui n'avait rien à voir
avec cette barbarie et salle abdeslam
toujours dans une stratégie de défense
en tant que combattant de l'état
islamique est encore intervenu et ce
après les dépositions à des personnes de
confession musulmane victimes des
attentats il a expliqué qu'il visait les
mécréants si nous avons attaqué des
musulmans at il dit ce n'était pas notre
intention
et il a expliqué à ses deux victimes il
a tenu des propos surréalistes
nous on n'a pas visé les musulmans si
votre soeur est décédé c'était un
accident de notre part vous imaginez
donc les protestations et l'indignation
dans la salle d'audience de la part des
parties civiles dont la dignité a
illuminé cette journée très pesante
et direction à présent les états unis où
joe biden doit faire face un nouveau
bras de fer diplomatique la politique du
président américain est la cible de
critiques du leader nord coréen dans un
discours kim jong-un rejette les
propositions de dialogue de washington
dans le même temps pyongyang affirme
avoir réalisé un test il y à deux jours
d'un missile hypersonique ce qui a
poussé le conseil de sécurité de l'onu a
organisé une réunion d'urgence demain on
retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir comme à
l comment les autorités américaines
j'appelle le dossier nord coréen
eh bien il ya une très forte inquiétude
par rapport à ce test effectué en début
de semaine par pyongyang les autorités
nord-coréennes affirment avoir réalisé
avec succès un tir d'essai d'un missile
hypersonique c'est un missile avec une
vitesse plus importante que les autres
et qui le rend plus difficile être
interceptées c'est un missile c'est une
technologie de pointe que très peu de
pays dans le monde possèdent
actuellement et c'est pour cette raison
qu'un qu'une réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies a été demandé
par la france le royaume uni et les
etats unis à l'heure initialement elle
devait se tenir ce jeudi elle aura
finalement lieu demain mais cette
réunion s'inscrit dans un climat de
défiance très grand entre pyongyang et
washington puisque cette semaine kim
jong-un a critiqué très vivement
l'attitude de washington en expliquant
que les propositions de dialogue n'était
qu'une façade dit il pour masquer les
fourberies des états unis et leurs
menaces militaires contre la corée du
nord le leader nord-coréen qui semble
vouloir poursuivre sa politique en
matière d'armement tant qu'il n'y a pas
véritablement de changement de cap de la
part de washington alors le porte parole
du département d'état américain a tenté
de désamorcer en quelque sorte la
situation en réitérant les appels au
dialogue et en affirmant que les états
unis n'avaient finalement aucune
intention hostile à l'égard de la corée
du nord est puis déjà la semaine
dernière à l'onu lors de son discours
lors de l'assemblée général des nations
unis joe biden avait lui aussi a fait
avancer son souhait de faire avancer les
choses justement en vue d'une
dénucléarisation de la péninsule
coréenne le sujet de la corée du nord
est finalement un sujet assez récurrent
qui revient régulièrement sur le bureau
de joe biden est également dans
l'actualité déjà au mois de mai dernier
lorsque joe biden avait reçu à la maison
blanche le président sud coréen il avait
déjà parlé de ce dossier nord-coréen
écouter
s'il s'engage et je le rencontrerai s'il
y avait un engagement pour lequel nous
nous rencontrions et cet engagement
implique qu'il y ait une discussion sur
son arsenal nucléaire et donc si c'était
le cas je ne le rencontrerait pas à
moins que mon secrétaire d'état et
d'autres personnes et négociés sur la
manière de procéder
mais force est de constater que les
choses n'avancent pas puisque pyongyang
continue de reprocher à washington et
bien les sanctions américaines contre le
pays ainsi que les exercices militaires
conjoints qui sont menées régulièrement
par séoul et washington les relations
sont en fait au point mort depuis le
mois de juin 2019 et l'échec de
l'organisation d'un sommet à l'époque
entre donald trump et kim jong-hun alors
après des premiers mois qu'on pourra
qualifier de délicats sur la scène
internationale joe biden espère
peut-être un peu plus de réussite sur le
dossier nord-coréen mais les dernières
évolutions et les dernières actualités
autour de ce dossier n'invite pas
réellement à l'optimisme pour le
locataire de la maison blanche merci
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
et les états unis justement toujours
très critiqué après leur décision de
fermer les frontières aux réfugiés
haïtiens des milliers de migrants
refoulés qui se retrouvent au mexique
beaucoup veulent désormais rester sur
cette nouvelle terre d'accueil est
détaillé avec michael dos santos
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport mexicain de
vie à hermosa ce mercredi 70 migrants
barque dans un avion à destination de
port au prince c'est le premier vol mis
en oeuvre dans le cadre d'un accord de
retour volontaire entre haïti et le
mexique
pour d'autres une longue attente
commence refoulé des états unis après la
décision de joe biden d'expulser quinze
mille migrants installés le long du
fleuve rio grande des nombres d'entre
eux veulent rester au mexique où il
demande d'asile des migrants démunis qui
fuient des pays gangréné par la violence
et qui veulent entamer une nouvelle vie
pour survivre
j'ai un fils et je ne veux pas qu'ils
grandissent en haïti car lorsque les
jeunes commence à grandir
s'il n'y a rien à faire ils se
retrouvent dans les gangs la drogue et
les mauvaises choses c'est mon seul fils
et j'essaye de trouver quelque chose de
mieux
j'ai besoin de travailler car j'ai une
femme et une fille et je dois acheter de
la nourriture
dans ce stade de tapachula au sud du
mexique les migrants reçoivent l'aide
d'avocats bénévoles pour faciliter leurs
démarches des procédures administratives
qui peuvent durer des mois face à
l'afflux massif le gouvernement a mis en
place une commission des de réfugiés
pour faciliter leur accueil et
enregistré leur demande d'asile l'idée
était de libérer des places pour les
nouveaux arrivants une demande faite à
la comar la commission mexicaine d'ado
réfugiés était qu'en raison de la
saturation du système de rendez vous les
nouveaux arrivants ne pouvait pas
obtenir de rendez vous
les haïtiens continuent d'être ceux qui
ont le plus grand nombre d'arrivées hier
78% des 804 personnes étaient des
haïtiens suivi des honduriens
pour le moment les autorités mexicaines
traite les demandes d'asile de 13 mille
haïtiens d'autres reconduction vers
haïti sont à prévoir dans prochains
jours
trois mois après la rencontre entre
vladimir poutine et joe biden en juin
dernier les discussions entre la russie
et les etats unis ont repris cette fois
ci à genève entre les numéro deux de la
diplomatie objectif de cette rencontre
tenterait de restaurer un dialogue
stratégique entre les deux puissances en
retrouve en direct de moscou notre
correspondant sur place antoine
claireaux sa bonne foi antoine que
retenir de ces échanges entre ces
dirigeants de la diplomatie russe et
américaine
oui stéphanie et bien sergueï riabkov et
wendy sherman ne s'en sont pas cachés
les deux pays ont toujours deux ou
d'importants différends sur ce thème de
la stabilité stratégique sur le contrôle
des armements mais malgré tout des
progrès ont été réalisés en effet des
deux diplomates se sont mis d'accord
concernant la formation de deux groupes
de travail sur ce sujet de la stabilité
de la stabilité stratégique j'écoutais
aujourd'hui nous sommes convenus de
créer deux groupes de travail qui au
niveau des experts couvriront tout le
champ
le premier groupe de travail s'occupera
des principes et objectifs de la
maîtrise des armements à l'avenir
le deuxième groupe de travail traitera
des questions de capacité d action qui
ont en effet stratégique
une fois nommé vous pouvez facilement le
voir ils couvrent tout le champ de notre
futur travail
et c'est une fois que les deux groupes
de travail seront à pied d'oeuvre qu'un
calendrier un nouveau cycle de
consultations entre moscou et washington
sera mise en place ces riabkov a
également annoncé qu'à partir du 5
octobre une commission bilatérale
toujours entre moscou et washington sera
elle également formés elle aura pour
charge de négocier l'extension du traité
new start de réduction des armements
stratégiques alors pas de grandes
annonces par des annonces
exceptionnelles donc mais étant donné
l'état déplorable des relations entre
les etats-unis et la russie et bien
cette continuité dans le dialogue et
puis c'est ces quelques progrès mérite
déjà d'être salué et antoine il a donc
été question des relations aux russes
américaine mais pas seulement la
question de l'alliance militaire accuse
dans l'inde au pacifique a aussi été
abordée
oui tout à fait cette rencontre a pu
permettre à la partie russe de
s'adresser directement la partie
américaine afin de demander des
éclaircissements concernant concernant
ce sujet de cette nouvelle alliance
entre les états unis l'australie et le
royaume uni et ses doutes ce concerne le
transfert possible de combustible
nucléaire concernant ses futurs sous
marins australiens la russie se
demandent en effet si les conséquences
de cette décision rentre dans le cadre
de la non-prolifération nucléaire et
s'inquiète des possibles risques de
détournement de ses activités nucléaires
d'un usage civil vers un usage du wihrel
usage militaire
merci antoine claireaux en direct depuis
moscou
et depuis sa nomination hier les
messages de félicitations se multiplient
en tunisie comme un international jeu-là
bouden est donc la première femme
tunisienne a accédé au poste de chef du
gouvernement
une première aussi dans le monde arabe
une avancée majeure et une victoire dans
la lutte des droits des femmes elle pour
ces magistrates politiques ou militantes
que notre correspondant à tunis ben
hassen chébili a rencontré
universitaire inconnu du grand public et
ancien chargé de mission auprès du
cabinet du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur
elle nage abou dehn a été désigné
mercredi par le chef de l'état qu'à
israël pour diriger le nouveau
gouvernement tunisien une désignation
dont la portée symbolique et salué par
de nombreuses associations de femmes
tunisiennes je vous propose de les
écouter
c'était une demande que nous avions déjà
formulée au chef de l'état à savoir des
femmes à des postes à haute
responsabilité que ce soit à la tête du
gouvernement ou au sein du gouvernement
nous souhaitions un gouvernement
paritaire donc c'est une chose positive
néanmoins nous ne pouvons pas donner
comme ça un chèque en blanc il faut un
programme clair et une vision commune
avec la présidence du gouvernement pour
que nous puissions nous aussi présenter
notre programme et la perception que
nous souhaitons de la société nous
voulons poursuivre dans la voie de la
démocratie tout en préservant nos acquis
notamment en matière de droits et
libertés individuelles l'aquitaine
nous avons accueilli avec joie à la
nomination d'une femme au poste de chef
du gouvernement
nous avions déjà demandé une meilleure
représentativité des femmes à des postes
de décision et nous continuerons de le
réclamer la femme tunisienne que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et plus que
qualifiées et compétentes
elle a toujours été une plus value sur
tous les plans et dans tous les domaines
tosi film hached aujourd'hui elle a plus
que le droit d'occuper des postes de
décision
moi en tout cas en tant que femme
politique j'ai accueilli la nouvelle
avec beaucoup de joie comme femme et
comme politicien avec beaucoup de jeu
reste un peu vigilante et sceptique
parce que c'est un poste très difficile
où il faut beaucoup d'abnégation il faut
une sorte de devoir d'ingratitude
pour mener à bien cette tâche surtout
dans la tunisie d'aujourd'hui où il y a
beaucoup de difficultés notamment
économiques et sociales ou les réformes
politiques certes sont très importantes
mais moi je les vois dans la phase
actuelle un peu secondaire par rapport
aux problèmes économiques et à la crise
sociale nous on avance en tout cas je
trouve que la tunisie a toujours était
progressiste depuis l'indépendance et
qu'en matière de droits des femmes et
même avant l'indépendance et qu'en
matière de droits des femmes on ne fait
que avancer même s'il ya eu des crises
au ca qui était vraiment très menacé une
avancée pour les droits de la femme une
formule qui revient très souvent depuis
la nomination de najlae bouden chargé
par le président de la république de
former un gouvernement dans les plus
brefs délais impossible toutefois de
savoir pour l'heure quelles seront les
priorités de la nouvelle chef du
gouvernement est nickel pouvoir lui
seront conférée par le chef de l'état en
attendant cahill sayed continue de
gouverner seul par décrets sans
parlement ni dialogue avec la classe
politique tunisienne aujourd'hui
toutefois la question est de savoir dans
quelle mesure la nomination de najlae
bouden équilibrera de quelque façon que
ce soit le contrôle total de l'homme
fort de la tunisie sur tous les aspects
du système politique et juridique
tunisien
rester avec nos dents quelques instants
s'intéressera au pouvoir d'achat des
français le premier ministre annonce ce
soir plusieurs coups de pouce jean
castex ça promet qu'il n'y aura plus
d'augmentation du prix du gaz après
celle de demain jusqu'en avril prochain
un bouclier tarifaire pour l'électricité
ou encore un chèque énergie 200 euros en
décembre des aides très attendue par les
ménages mais ces annonces seront elles
suffisantes on en débattra dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
en afghanistan le passage du pouvoir aux
talibans après vingt ans de guerre est
une défaite pour l'ensemble des
occidentaux en tant que membre de l'otan
un pays comme la france peut se poser
des questions sur la vision américaine
de l'organisation et la prise de
contrôle du marché des sous marins
australiens par les états unis montrent
qu'une alliance entre anglo saxons pour
faire face à la chine est en train de se
construire c'est un signe manifeste
d'une longue dégringolade de notre
posture à la fois stratégiques
politiques sur la scène internationale
et industriels aussi les pays européens
sont ils perçus comme des pourvoyeurs de
troupes de supplétifs au service des
états unis ou bien des alliés et de
véritables partenaires
[Musique]
à la veille à d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction dantec ce soit
possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre en
direct pour cette deuxième partie
d'émission au sommaire ce soir comment
soulager le porte monnaie des français
le premier ministre annonce ce soir
plusieurs coups de pouce j'encaisse est
trop mais qui n'y aura plus
d'augmentation du prix du gaz pendant
sept mois sept mois à la date d'ailleurs
des prochaines présidentielles et celle
de demain d'ailleurs il promet aussi un
bouclier tarifaire pour l'électricité ou
encore un chèque énergie 200 euros en
décembre des êtres est attendue pour les
ménages mais ces mesures seront elles
suffisantes notamment pour éviter la
grogne des français le débat est ouvert
[Musique]
les tarifs de l'énergie s'envolent tout
le marché mondial est concernée en
france le prix du gaz augmentera de plus
de 12 % dès demain l'électricité devait
aussi connaître une nouvelle
augmentation d'environ 12% en début
d'année prochaine une hausse brutale
pour des millions de français qui oblige
donc le gouvernement à réagir ce soir tu
es au combat
57 % de hausse depuis janvier du jamais
vu les prix du gaz ne cesse de flamber
depuis le début de l'année après de
fortes hausses durant l'été le comité de
régulation de l'énergie vient d'annoncer
une nouvelle augmentation effective dès
ce vendredi au 1er octobre 2021 le
comité de régulation de l'énergie
constate que les tarifs réglementés de
vente de gaz naturel d'énergie
augmentent de 12,6 pour cent une grosse
problématique à l' approche de l'hiver
mais surtout de la future présidentielle
après l'annoncé d'une aide de 100 euros
supplémentaires pour les ménages les
plus modestes
en plus du chèque énergie le
gouvernement se veut offensif sur le
sujet nous allons mettre pour le gaz
pour l'électricité en place ce que
j'appellerais un bouclier tarifaire
c'est à dire nous allons prémunir contre
ces hausses de tarifs parce que
malheureusement que nous disent les
experts c'est que ça va continuer la
décision gpse s'appelle des prix
réglementés corps ya un peu plus de 5
millions de nos concitoyens qui sont
concernés par ces hausses réelles et à
venir
nous allons bloquer bloqué il n'y aura
plus d'augmentation du prix du gaz c'est
à dire celles qui sont envisagées j'ai
ce pouvoir de par les textes simplement
ce que je vous dis c'est que je vous
donnerai une clause de revoyure c'est à
dire si effectivement au mois de mars
avril les baisses liées aux cours
mondiaux ne se produise pas alors nous
devrons pour que ce que vous décrivez ne
se produise pas prendre des mesures
complémentaires qui pourraient
effectivement être des mesures de
baisses de taxes rappelons qu'en
novembre 2018 c'est aussi une hausse des
prix de l'énergie en l'occurrence du
carburant qui avait mis le feu aux
poudres et déclenché une colère
populaire qui avait abouti au mouvement
des gilet jaune un scénario qui emmanuel
macron ne souhaite surtout pas voir se
représenter au risque de mettre à mal sa
probable candidature pour l'élection
suprême d'avril prochain je vous
remercie mais les mesures annoncées par
le premier ministre répond elle aux
besoins des français face à la plomber
flambée des prix du gaz de l'électricité
et blessant suffisant pour éviter une
nouvelle grogne place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler puis si la ludo
ski etc ce gilet jaune au bon soin à
priscilla du dos qui merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ce plateau joseph
thouvenel secrétaire national de la cftc
bon soit également souvent à vous vous
avez certainement suivi ou peut-être
n'avait pas eu le temps vous étiez
peut-être dans la voiture pour venir ici
les annonces de de jean castex qui
annonce donc le gel de la hausse du prix
du gaz ce soir celle de demain en
revanche aura bien lieu promet également
un bouclier tarifaire pour l'électricité
ou encore un chèque énergie 200 euros
pour décembre joseph thouvenel ça vous
paraît suffisant aujourd'hui pour l'esc
est un peu choquant c'est qu'on voit des
échéances et justement ça va jusqu'où
présidentielle ils savent la pression
d'être un peu manipulé d'autant plus que
la ministre de l'ecologie barbe arabe
ont pu nous dire deux jours
l'électricité augmentation sera obligé
de 12 % en février et ce soir le premier
ministre à yves remise en eau non pas du
tout ça ne sera que 4 % ou ne se parlent
pas et ça s'appelle de l'incompétence où
il nous manipulent et 4% d'augmentation
d'électricité c'est deux fois plus que
l'inflation après s'il ya un bouclier si
les prix sont régulés si le gouvernement
empêche ces hausses extraordinaire
formidable au sens étymologique du terme
serre qui font peur parce que les gens
n'ont pas les moyens il faut qu'il
réalise et même s'il ya des gestes qui
sont faits avec un chèque de 100 euros
pour quelques familles enfin quelques
familles ça touche quelques milieux
payer les plus les moins argentés mais
toute la classe moyenne 1 il ne touche
rien et pourtant ils payent plein pot et
on a de plus en plus de gens qui
effectivement l'hiver renoncent à se
chauffer ou seule chose de moins en
moins
à ce que n'ont pas les moyens et donc là
l'action du gouvernement très bien si
réguler l'immédiatement mais aussi il
faut qu'ils réfléchissent sur le long
terme pour reprendre la main parce que
ça ce sont des biens essentiels
c'est pas des biens je sais pas je vais
pas au parc d'attractions
j'ai besoin de me chauffer j'ai besoin
de l'électricité j'ai besoin de l'eau et
quand on regarde les taxes de l'état
nous dire on va réguler c'est très bien
sur l'électricité qu'elles sont le c'est
34 % de notre facture d'électricité
quand on la paye
34% en taxes diverses et variées alors
il ya de la marge pour les tares et le
gaz c'est 21% quand même de taxes donc
ils peuvent dire on régule oui
effectivement il suffit de baisser les
taxes priscilla du dock ce qui est
justement vous auriez entendu vous
d'autres annoncent au soir de jean
castex notamment peut-être qu'une baisse
d'eads est apte ou vous êtes plutôt
satisfaite de ce que vous avez entendu
ce soir
louis dont soir oui effectivement c'est
toujours bien de commencer par des
mesures qui permettent de réduire c'est
ses os même mais effectivement moi je
pars toujours évidemment de la taxe
carbone et un ace que jean je n'entends
pas c'est la suppression de cette tva on
assure la taxe terrebonne 60% de taxes
et une tva sur la taxe donc en fait
c'est une double c'est très punitive
quoi c'est vraiment et est-ce que c'est
légal déjà gelé la question que je pose
sur le film est une tva sur une tasse
donc pourquoi pas les gérer abolir cette
tva sur cette taxe et et réduire
considérablement le pourcentage de cet
axe est énorme c puis la moitié du tarif
donc je trouve ça assez assez dommage
qu'ils aient fait un geste là dessus
qu'on me tenir en plus du démarrage de
du mouvement léger les jeunes qui part
effectivement de cette incompréhension
l'a1 à côté de ça je pense qu'il faut
pas oublier aussi le phénomène de la
crise sanitaire qui a entraîné et
peut-être que ça a été intéressant pour
pas mal de gens de pouvoir travailler à
distance et donc le télétravail engendre
aussi des hausses de de consommation
d'énergie puisque on à domicile
l'ordinateur est allumé toute la journée
et ce qu'il fait froid on a le chauffage
en plus calmes et toute la journée là où
avant on utilisait l'ordinateur du
travail et où on éteignait le chauffage
la journée pour justement faire des
économies toutes ces hausses fait ce qu
elles sont accompagnées par les
entreprises qu'est ce qui se passe quand
aux entreprises pour accompagner les
salariés qui travaillent à domicile il
ya peut-être aussi quelque chose à faire
là dessus et effectivement même si ces
aides chèque énergie et autres donnent
l'impression de donner du pouvoir
d'achat pouvoir le pouvoir d'achat c'est
le niveau de revenus qui devraient
permettre
satisfaire ses besoins primaires or on a
quand même 9 millions et quelques de
personnes qui sont sous le seuil de
pauvreté donc ces personnes là est ce
que réellement elle peut subvenir à
leurs besoins première question et le
pouvoir d'achat c'est à pouvoir de vivre
on ne va pas travailler toute la journée
à se fatiguer pour simplement pouvoir
payer ses factures qui ne cesse
d'augmenter il ya peut-être aussi cette
volonté de pouvoir vivre de ceux de son
du fruit de son travail alors selon le
premier ministre je précise quand même
le pouvoir d'achat des français le seul
à avoir légèrement progressé en 2020 par
rapport aux pays qui nous entourent une
comme iso il augmentera pardon en 2021
de 1,5 pour cent
joseph thouvenel ça vous inspire quoi
cette remarque de jean castex ont droit
en gros s'estimer heureux ça m'inspire
que j'aime bien vérifier les chiffres du
gouvernement avec les avec les sources
parce que regarder on nous parle et là
on nous parle moins des retraites on
vous parlait beaucoup des retraites et
du difficile des retraites qui devait
être mais leur colossal il doit être de
23 milliards ça c'était les prévisions
les chiffres sur basé sur les recherches
oui enfin c'est 13 milliards terre qu'à
10 milliards comme ça qu'ils vont qui
viennent
le pouvoir d'achat tout le monde enfin
tous ceux qui vivent normalement savent
qu'ils étaient atteints que le pouvoir
d'achat baisse plutôt parce que les
charges augmentent parce que les charges
ceux qui payent des impôts de plus en
plus d'impôts il ya des taxes ce qui
arrive si je ne paye pas d'impôts je
paye des tv ça a été dit à juste titre
je vais le redire quand même là les
taxes diverses sur l'électricité c'est
34 % de notre facture ça ne fait que
croître et embellir ça explose sur le
gaz c'est pareil et sur l'eau c'est la
même chose
et donc là on perd du pouvoir d'achat
parce que le chiffre de l'infraction est
totalement fausse et regardez bien
comment est constitué l'étude sur
l'inflation et quels sont les produits
qu'il rentre pas dedans par exemple
logement n'est pas dedans le logement
c'est accessoire ça coûte pas cher et se
loger c'est pas calculer et pourtant je
crois savoir que le logement coûte de
plus en plus cher c'est pour ça que ces
chiffres
il ya la vie réelle et il ya la
stratégie de communication alors même si
les choses sont pas faciles même si le
gouvernement n'a pas de baguette magique
les français on est prêt à affronter la
réalité parce que là voir le tout le
monde entier
le prix de l'énergie il expose proches
et tout le monde parce qu'il ya des pays
qui sont producteurs pour qu'elle
s'expose sport après il ya des erreurs
qui ont été faites on a vu qu arrêter un
réacteur nucléaire
ça nous coûte très cher les britanniques
ont mis rond tout base et enfin car leur
énergie sur l'éolienne oui et le
problème c'est que là ils ont eut ils
ont pas eu de vent à 8
ce soir effectivement aujourd'hui dans
une interview que la faute notamment aux
énergies renouvelables et aux éoliennes
et en europe c'est dommage avec les yeux
ne pas dire que faut pas aller sur les
énergies renouvelables
mais il faut que la transition soit fait
intelligemment c'est à dire que quand on
arrête quelque chose c'est parce qu'on a
le remplacement mais pour le moment elle
n'a pas apprécié dans le dos qui vous on
se souvient vous aviez lancé le
mouvement des gilet jaune avec une
pétition d'ailleurs sur l'augmentation
du prix de l'essence qui lui aussi est
faramineux ça atteint des records en ce
moment jean castex d'ailleurs nous
rappelle ce que le soir que le chèque
énergie était instaurée sous le
quinquennat à la suite du mouvement des
gilet jaune si les mesures ne sont pas
suffisantes le gouvernement est prêt
justement à revoir ce chèque à la hausse
vous avez l'impression d'avoir été
entendus
non d'ailleurs j'en parlais je disais
que proportions énormes de cette
taxation éclaté vers et et pèse encore
il ya aussi ce sujet d'inégalités de
l'application de cette taxe où tout le
monde n'est pas logé à la même enseigne
et où on pensait bien que
l'automobiliste et ea est le plus gros
pollueurs il en fait partie mais pas que
et donc à quel moment on répartit cette
charge punitive sur les autres pollueurs
à on a aussi en fait même sur cet axe là
haut ou sur les autres taxes sur les
produits de première nécessité on n'a
pas de lien aux moyens des personnes qui
qui paie ses taxes cela veut dire allez
pas la taxe n'est pas indexé au niveau
de revenu des gens et aussi au niveau
des alternatives présents sur le
territoire parce que la pétition à
questionner ça aussi avisé vous
augmenter les taxes sur le carburant
notamment
1 en disant qu'il fallait qu'on puisse
alterné nos modes de transport de mode
de déplacement or dans certaines zones
et c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui
c'est à dire c'était déjà dénoncé il ya
un moment par les mouvements qui m'a et
autres s'étaient dénoncés dans le cas du
mouvement des jets les jeunes à travers
la pétition aujourd'hui avec on est
presque à une fin de quinquennat est ce
que des alternatives de transport ont
été mises en place dans certains
territoires qui dans ce cas dans ce cas
là le mettraient leur permettrait de ne
pas prendre leur véhicule parce que du
coup on a des personnes qui sont qui ont
des alternatives dans certains
territoires qui vont payer cette taxe
qui va continuer d'augmenter et d'autres
qui n'ont toujours pas d'alternative
aujourd'hui mais qui vont aussi subir la
hausse de cette taxe donc en fait c'est
très fier très inégalement répartie et
cet axe là ce sont des impôts indirects
mais ils sont absolument pas indexé sur
le revenu et donc on a en plus une
nouvelle réforme sur le chômage qui
entre en vigueur ou l'unedic nous
annonce que en moyenne
un plus d'un million je crois que c'est
un million points 15 de français qui
touche ces indemnités qui ne qui verront
diminuer leur indemnité de 10 7% et
c'est encore énorme donc je veux dire
j'ai l'impression que c'est le chien qui
se mord la queue on met un pansement
avec ces chèques énergie mais par
ailleurs on fait pas ce qu'il faut pour
réellement donné du vrai pouvoir d'achat
mais pouvoir de vivre dignement sein de
la société je vais pas tout venelles sur
cette question justement du prix de
l'essence a même chose trop trop de
taxes je pensais tu laisses moi j'ai la
chance d'habiter en banlieue parisienne
donc d'avoir des transports en commun
mais combien de millions de personnes
n'ont pas le choix doivent utiliser leur
véhicule pour aller au travail pour les
enfants à l'école pour aller à la poste
qui n'existe plus pour aller voir je ne
sais trop quel service qui a été déplacé
et quand on voit le prix mais que je
connais je connais des gens qui met 15
euros par 15 euros parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens de faire le plein et 15
euros aujourd'hui c'est encore beaucoup
moins dans leur voiture que ce qui
mettait hier donc le problème il est
absolument pas résolu le problème il est
là il faut enfin il faut prendre
conscience que des millions de personnes
souffrent
c'est pas des gens qu'on entend beaucoup
on a entendu seul et gilet jaune sur le
gilet jaune moi je n'aime pas du tout
l'image qui a été donnée transmis par
quelques par les black blocs qui sont
emparés à certains moments les liaisons
ne sais pas ça les gène jones et les
braves gens désespérés temps dit on en a
ras-le-bol on a pu les moyens et on se
met sur les ronds-points pour dire il y
en a ras-le-bol message il est géré au
delà moi je suis entièrement avec eux
parce qu'ils ont raison quand on voit
leurs difficultés quotidiennes de vie il
ya le chauffage à l'essence mais à tout
le reste les transports qui ne sont plus
là les transports collectifs le là parce
que les plats les villages qui se
désertifient ça c'est la réalité alors
ça peut pas se régler d'un coup de
baguette magique encore une fois mais je
vois pas les grands efforts qui sont
faits pour aider ces gens et puis aider
ces gens ça passe pour ceux qui
travaillent la revalorisation des
salaires les plus bas parce qu'en france
les salaires sont bas notamment des
professions difficile d'éprouver toutes
les professions qui s'occupe de la
personne
c'est très peu payés la restauration
l'hôtellerie le
dans le bâtiment etc etc là il ya un
véritable travail à faire parce que
qu'on aille pas me dire que c'est la
concurrence internationale qui fait que
les salaires sont bas pour les
caissières de supermarché où les
salaires sont bas de région du bâtiment
chez nous parce que ça se délocalise pas
alors là on pourrait faire et on doit
faire des efforts et ses récits la vidéo
ce qui vous pensez qu'on vase échapper
justement à ce mouvement un nouveau
mouvement des gilet jaune avec ce qu'on
vient d'évoquer
ben j'ai envie de dire que pas mal de
choses ont été dénoncés des
revendications qui vont dans le sens de
ce qu'on vient d'évoquer ce soir par
exemple avait déjà été transmis au
gouvernement à travers le ministre de la
transition écologique de l'époque
d'autres ministres en quatre rencontres
et entre temps beaucoup de députés
auront été rencontré les sénateurs je
pense que globalement avec en plus ses
associations les organisations
syndicales mêmes et d'autres d'autres
organismes qui se battent au quotidien
pour notamment comme attaque par exemple
ont déjà transmis un certain nombre de
projets qui visent à réduire les
inégalités sociales or j'ai pas
l'impression que ça que ça change grand
chose et on voit des personnes qui ont
la manifester au sein du mouvement des
gilet jaune qui se manifestent toujours
à travers d'autres d'autres mouvements
qui oeuvre pour la justice sociale et
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu une
veille une veille de la population qui
dit on en a ras-le-bol et qu'elle sera
toujours présente peut-être pas de
l'ampleur qu'ont inconnues mais selon
moi il y aura toujours une manière ou
une autre de se manifester y avait
beaucoup de gens qui sont manifestés sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment pendant la
crise parce que c'était un des moyens de
communication les plus simples
évidemment à ce moment là mais voilà je
ne sais pas si ça prendra comme ça a
pris avant mais je pense que beaucoup de
choses ont été déjà dénoncé à travers ce
mouvement pendant sur la durée en plus
ça c'est une technique durée assez
inédite et inattendue et en plus avec
une intensité qui a trouvé en face à une
violence policière qui a laissé des
personnes sont membres et notamment
beaucoup des borniers ont vu le contexte
un pouvoir d'achat évidemment s'apprête
à être un enjeu très fort de cette
campagne présidentielle certains
candidats ont d'ailleurs déjà fait des
propositions c'est le cas de marine le
pen au rassemblement national mais aussi
de jean luc mélenchon pour la france a
soumises
on va agir sur l'essence le gaz
l'électricité le prix des péages et la
redevance il y a comme ça toute une
série de mesures qui permettront de
restituer 150 à 200 euros par mois par
français c'est le moins que l'on puisse
faire les gens ne s'en sortent
absolument plus faut qu'ils se
réveillent il y a dix millions de
pauvres dans le pays
la chose à faire tout de suite c'est de
bloquer les prix sur les produits de
première nécessité je vous garantis
qu'on nous ruinera personnes en faisant
saint joseph thouvenel a un sens sans
nous dévoiler évidemment vos préférences
politiques c'est pas le sujet mais
aujourd'hui clairement vous sentez que
cette question du pouvoir d'achat ça va
être l'un des thèmes forts et qu'il y
aura des vraies réponses de la part des
candidats des vraies réponses au sérieux
en tout cas de la part des candidats moi
j'attends pas les réponses j'attends les
acteurs et quand ils sont élus
tout le monde constate donc que ce soit
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui
devient un problème de pouvoir d'achat
et un problème d'inflation qui repart ya
un problème de prix de l'énergie et
d'autres prix il faut aussi se poser la
question des économies qui peuvent être
faits et tout à l'heure je suis tombé
sur un article du nouvel obs
qui date un petit peu mais pas tant que
ça en trois ans l'état français dépensé
43 milliards d'euros je me trompe pas je
parle bien de milliards 43 milliards
d'euros pour des cabinets conseils
internationaux pour faire des travaux
que les hauts fonctionnaires peuvent
faire alors soit nos fonctionnaires sont
nulles faut pas les garder un mais 43
milliards d'euros en trois ans qui ont
été dépensés pour des cabinets
internationaux de conseil ça me
scandalise profondément et pour des
tâches qui sont normalement dévolue aux
fonctionnaires ben voilà 43 milliards
d'euros sur trois ans vous voyez ce
qu'on peut faire comme économie
prescilla le dos qui le mot de la fin
pour vous sur sa campagne qui s'annonce
et les solutions peut-être des candidats
ce que vous restez optimiste
alors j'ai envie de dire
qu'effectivement vu le dernier sondage
de toute confiance des français envers
les politiques et de 11% ce qui est rien
du tout effectivement je pense que ce
qui se dit dans les programmes doit se
traduire dans les actes en fait
restaurer la confiance des gens ça se
fait pas à l'occasion d'une campagne je
pense que là à ce stade les gens
attendraient le monde et du vrai
changement dans leur quotidien merci en
tout cas tous les deux joseph thouvenel
prescilla le dock ski d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france merci roue
et on vient d'entendre avec nos invités
les annonces donc du gouvernement
pourrait être insuffisant pour répondre
à la hausse des prix autre sujet qui
fait grincer des dents les syndicats la
réforme de l'assurance chômage on en
parle elle aussi un entrent en vigueur
demain un projet de décret été transmis
aux partenaires sociaux il reprend
quasiment mot pour mot le contenu de
celui du 30 mars dernier une application
partiellement suspendu par le conseil
d'état le 22 juin les syndicats
qualifient et cette réforme injuste pour
les demandeurs d'emploi et déjà des
razak
encourager les chômeurs de longue durée
à retrouver du travail c'est
officiellement l'objectif de la réforme
de l'assurance chômage après de nombreux
recours et plusieurs reports une partie
du texte entre en vigueur
le 1er octobre la réforme est le fruit
de six mois des changes ininterrompue
avec les partenaires sociaux elle repose
sur deux principes lutter contre la
précarité et assurer plus d'équité dans
le calcul des allocations chômage la
réforme ne réduit pas les droits des
allocataires alors si justement car elle
durcit entre autres les règles de calcul
de l'allocation chômage le salaire
journalier de référence le sjr est
nécessaire pour calculer cette
allocation jusqu'ici le montant a été
obtenu en divisant le salaire brut total
perçu au cours des douze derniers mois
par le nombre de jours travaillés
il est désormais calculé en divisant ce
salaire par l'ensemble des jours
travaillés ou non alors selon l'unedic
en charge de la gestion de l'assurance
chômage plus d'un million de personnes
devraient voir leurs allocations
journalières amputé de 10 7% en moyenne
de plus la durée minimale d'activité
salariée pour l'ouverture des droits à
l'assurance chômage passe elle de quatre
à six mois emmanuel macron a commencé
son quinquennat avec la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune et l'une de ses
dernières mesures sera la remise en
cause des droits de ceux qui souffrent
le plus les chômeurs avant on calculer
vos droits en fonction des salaires
touchés mais avec ce nouveau calcul très
compliquée du salaire journalier on
prend en compte les périodes où vous
n'avez pas travaillé ce qui est un
comble quant aux six mois des changes
ininterrompue avec les partenaires
sociaux évoqué par elisabeth bornes pas
sûr que ces derniers soient d'accord
avec la prise en compte de leurs avis
que revendique la ministre du travail
opposés à cette réforme depuis le début
elles les organisations syndicales
continuent de faire part de leur colère
alors que les prix de l'énergie et du
carburant flambe le nouveau mode de
calcul du salaire journalier de
référence va dé facto amputée de
plusieurs centaines d'euros les
allocations d'un million de demandeurs
d'emploi qui enchaîne les petits
contrats cette diminution est d'autant
plus problématique que 50 % des
allocataires touchent moins de 860 euros
net par mois cette réforme les syndicats
annoncent qu'ils continuent de la
combattre devant le conseil d'état mais
aussi dans la rue l intersyndicale
appelle à une mobilisation partout en
france le 5 octobre
mais avant de se quitter petit détour du
côté de l'espagne quatre ans après la
tentative d'indépendance de la catalogne
les indépendantistes célèbre
l'anniversaire du référendum
d'autodétermination
un anniversaire un petit peu spéciales
ont fait le point avec notre
correspondante à barcelone clémentine
laurent ce 1er octobre cela fera quatre
ans que les catalans ont voté pour
l'indépendance de la région durant un
référendum non autorisées un scrutin qui
même plusieurs années après et toujours
lourd de conséquences après le
référendum en 2017 les dirigeants
indépendantistes responsable de ce
dernier avait été condamné et emprisonné
et même s'ils avaient été graciés en
juin dernier il ne s'agit pas d'une
amnistie totale si les récidives ils
iront en prison et il reste à
aujourd'hui inéligible il ya aussi les
maires qui sont responsable également de
l'organisation du référendum dans les
autres villes de catalogne qui sont
toujours en attente de jugement et puis
surtout il y à la sphère putsch damon
l'ancien président catalan qui avait
déclaré l'indépendance a aujourd'hui en
espagne il est toujours en exil il est
recherché par la police espagnole et
même si la possibilité d'extrader push
damon vers l'espagne reste compliquée et
bien c'est toujours l'objectif des
tribunaux espagnols alors les
manifestations et événements prévus ce
week-end de dureront trois jours durant
lesquels les indépendantistes
revendiqueront notamment
l'autodétermination de la catalogne mais
aussi surtout l'aministie total de
khaled ce push damon et des autres
dirigeants indépendantistes qui avaient
été condamnées en 2017
reste à savoir si ces appels seront
entendus par madrid ou bien si le
gouvernement espagnol demeurera
inflexible sur ces questions et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi pour un
prochain
numéro en attendant l'actualité continue
toute la soirée devant tout le week-end
sur rt france
[Musique]
mais celle dont on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique
coloniale était de venir en territoire
et prendre les enfants sans le
consentement des parents et ils
arrachent et de leur territoire pour les
amis